my name is Shannon Rose McAuliffe and
I'm the manager of the student arts
programs here at MIT on behalf of the
entire office of the Arts welcome and
thank you all so much for joining us in
our newly virtual 15k creative arts
competition pitch finale tonight is our
eighth annual pitch finale for the 15k
competition since 2013 the 15k has
served as an incubator for creative
entrepreneurial startups and has helped
a dozens of student teams grow their
ideas into influential businesses at the
intersection of arts and innovation we
had 17 creative entrepreneurship
ventures apply to the competition this
year throughout the entire process the
teams have demonstrated truly impressive
improvement and a remarkably collegial
collaborative spirit all of the teams
are to be commended for their
flexibility perseverance and integrity
in the midst of so much unexpected
upheaval following a round of judging
six finalists have emerged for the
chance to win $15,000 towards supporting
their projects it's been a privilege to
witness the growth that each team has
undergone on their journey here this
afternoon this competition was designed
to provide benefit to creative ventures
at all levels and it's important to note
that all 17 initial teams were offered
the opportunity to experience the three
key aspects of the 15k the
is idea development and workshops each
team received thorough feedback from
seasoned arts professionals on their
initial applications which helped the
teams to hone and clarify their projects
teams also attended a series of targeted
workshops with experts in the area of
creative entrepreneurship designed to
accelerate all ventures during the
competition period these workshops were
tailored toward topics such as value
propositions long term business
sustainability and perfecting the art of
storytelling through the live pitch
though these experiences through these
experiences our teams have grown their
ideas and their business savvy on a
broad scale and these workshops are
augmented by more granular individual
mentorship all participants experience
one-on-one mentorship sessions with
distinguished MIT faculty and alumni
creative entrepreneurs artists attorneys
marketing specialists and industry
leaders all of queen' provide nuanced
insight and expertise into helping teams
develop their projects and all of this
happens through a platform called mentor
Lee the 15k and mentor Lee have been
working together for three years now and
the role they played this year was
instrumental in pairing our teams with
suggested mentors data and schedule
management and stewarding the mentorship
process for everyone involved the teams
cumulatively undertook 39 independent
one-on-one mentoring sessions in
addition to the aforementioned rounds of
feedback workshops and mock pitch events
the third integral element of the 15k
competition comes down to a single word
and that's connections our studio teams
make connections with other students
with alumni and with industry Mentors
this network continues to bolster and
support them even after graduation as
they seek opportunities to bring their
ideas to fruition and this year's
process culminating in today's finale
would not have been possible without the
expertise guidance and support from the
MIT community
I'd like to take a moment and extend
special thanks to our mentors and
first-round judges who volunteered their
time knowledge resources and insightful
expertise throughout this process
we've also got our workshop leaders from
thought cafe creative reframe space us
and our mock pitch panel these people
all spent hours talking to these teams
about their entrepreneurial experiences
and sharing information with our teams
thank you also to mentor Leah for
providing us with constant support and
an online platform to facilitate and
track our mentoring sessions I also owe
a tremendous debt of gratitude to my
inimitable colleagues in the MIT Office
for the Arts for their insights support
and for assisting me with turning this
into a virtual event this wouldn't have
been possible without them and I'd also
like to give a huge thanks to teach to
learn who are the 2019 winners of the
15k and they'll be providing an update
tonight while our judges deliberate and
on the topic of judges enthusiastic
thanks to our estimable panel of
finalists judges including Josh Roy
Wendy sport Grossman Philip Johnson he
Marcone des Mary Hale irani cozy and
Mark Stiglitz who have been and continue
to be champions of this competition so
before we commence with the pitches I'm
gonna go over a bit of housekeeping for
attendees competitors and judges alike
please keep your audio muted and keep
your camera off unless you are speaking
each team will have five minutes to
pitch to the panel five minutes for
questions from judges and one minute for
transition when there are 60 seconds
left on the timer you will hear a
dinging sound and when there are 60
after the 60 seconds has lasts you will
hear the dinging sound replayed and
we're going to endeavour to stick it to
this timing schedule as closely as we
can after the six pitches judges will
exit for a 45 minute deliberation period
where you'll have an opportunity to ask
questions of our teams participate in
audience choice voting and to hear an
update from our 2019 winner teach to
learn if you have any questions for the
teams throughout the event please submit
them via the Q&A button at the bottom of
your screen and now we're gonna do a
quick roll call teams please come on
camera and give us a wave when you're
called first up tonight we have Jeromy
and David with verify then we have Allen
and Derrick with ARC live
then we've got Carolyn and Natasha with
partner following that we have Michael
and Maria with elements then we'll have
Joe and iris with material futures lab
and we have pew sh representing unmake
now I wish all of the competitors good
luck and good skill and let's start
pitching team rarefied you're up okay
all right so hello everyone my name is
David Rosen Wasser
and I'm Jeremy bellotti we are excited
to tell you about our new design brand
called verify
so to give you some background I started
collecting and restoring the vintage
designer furniture as a high school
student by flipping chairs from
Craigslist just as I was worrying about
how to pay for architecture school a
store owner in the Philippines saw what
I was doing and decided to acquire all
of the inventory that I had at the time
that let me start a real business while
helping to pay for college
fast forward to today I've spent nearly
10 years running
d-rose ma during this time I have
restored hundreds of iconic pieces of
furniture spend thousands of hours
researching and changed hands with over
5,000 pieces so David and I go way back
in fact he was actually the first person
that I met at architecture school
so as we both studied and David grew his
business I was becoming fascinated with
the intersections of design and
technology I ended up working at
interdisciplinary design studios then at
the self-assembly lab here at MIT and
with Microsoft research I became
fascinated with how machine learning and
data science will transform the way we
interact with design now David and I are
ready to disrupt the furniture buying
experience using cutting-edge technology
so the designer furniture market today
is worth over twenty five billion
dollars however there are a number of
issues facing collectors when looking to
buy authentic vintage or new designer
furniture it's really hard for consumers
to know what's real and what's fake
what's a good investment and what is not
brands and consumers have come to trust
like cb2 restoration hardware and room
and board have been capitalizing off of
knockoffs for decades even with high
prices let's look at Sam and Alex for
instance Sam bought a high quality of
vintage Barcelona chair for 3k and Alex
spent the same money on a fake one years
later Sam still has a fantastic
investment where as Alex's chair is hard
to sell and has about 10% of its
original value that's right David
so collectors of the future want to know
that they're investing in real value and
that value needs to be verified they're
more informed than ever so they need
access to the most collectible pieces
out there
that's why we founded rarefied on the
values of transparency and quality
our mission is to make the furniture
buying experience
more transparent and informative using
big data so here's how we'll do it first
rare fly carries collectibles of the
past present and future we collaborate
with emerging designers to make new
furniture alongside our recent and
vintage inventory next we show our
customers the authenticity and the value
of each vintage piece verified by
experts and machine learning
lastly we sell direct to consumer we
leverage our existing supply chain of
fabricators craftspeople
and shippers
we have over a decade of experience
bringing investment worthy furniture to
collectors and now we're launching as a
design and tech company we use data
science to bring collectors more
information more clarity and more
confidence
so how exactly does our tech work well
our proprietary authentication
technology uses machine learning to
verify details about each piece such as
this chair
so this means material form condition
the presence of labels it also assesses
the pieces investment potential based on
things like market prices and even the
designers social media presence
finally it assigns it a score which
collectors can see alongside of verified
experts score our authentication
technology is going to revolutionize the
way collectors buy rare furniture
thanks Jenny so what is the e-commerce
furniture landscape to look like today
there are a lot of ways to buy designer
furniture online and the fastest-growing
segment is high-end designer resale
which includes vintage according to the
US Chamber of Commerce
now there are two primary competitors
both of which are growing rapidly first
dip sells high-dollar items within a
luxury market whereas cherish is more
oriented toward decor and lower value
items in comparison rarefied is a
disrupter setting a standard for
authentication and transparency unlike
the competition now part of the market
growth is because there's three hundred
and fifty billion dollars in high-end
collectibles now our business model
relies on commissions from our partner
dealers like viewers mod verifies
in-house inventory new designer
collaborations and revenue from our
authentication technology an opportunity
from 15k will provide critical rocket
fuel allowing us to further develop our
back-end tech and our first designer
collaboration lastly with our skills
complementing one another and our
passions going in the same direction we
are ready to program fly into something
that is truly special
thank you so much thank you thank you so
much
and now we'll have some Q&A from our
judges mark the purchasing of furniture
for collection a significant part of the
market order people just buy furniture
freebies including vintage furniture so
we're trying to look at so I've been a
pretty extensive background in dealing
with this furniture and and the reality
is that for many of these pieces they
are indeed investments that people look
at as both something that they can look
at everyday but also as something that's
a collectible piece that someone is
concerned about their value and I have I
have customers pretty frequently who ask
you know what kind of Eames lounge
chairs should they buy based upon the
collectability and rarity and so that's
something that we're hugely attentive to
you as well as applying those ideas to
the new collections and how we engage in
collectible designers and new
collections as well
wonderful Phillip thanks I you know for
me what's interesting about this is the
this idea of an authentication tech you
know that there is some way that through
machine learning you could create
something that couldn't be fooled or and
so a lot of that has to do with like
like learn like having a lot of access
to the data about the original stuff as
well as how does anyone trust your
authentication like you know if there's
one thing I do know there's there's ways
to fool you know you know sort of
verification you know facial recognition
and so if people were able to study your
your process couldn't they just find a
way to fool your tech yeah I think
that's a really good point
so I mean part of our mission is
definitely to promote transparency and
kind of expose all of the data of
perhaps that we use in a way that helps
give people confidence obviously there's
a limit to that transparency because it
is an intellectual property and we want
to kind of preserve that as part of our
business but on the consumer end we will
be prioritizing kind of sharing which
features we're looking at and also
documenting each piece to a higher
standard than what's on the market today
so you might be able to see the piece
that you're looking at identify every
scratch spin it in 3d on the website and
also understand the features and the
decisions that went into scoring that
piece how we can kind of keep it private
and protect our IP is that the data set
that we're using is actually one that we
already have so we have a whole
collection of images and labeled data
that we can work with already and start
training our models on right away and
that's all taken by us and by David or
the course of his ten years running the
Rosemont all right Josh
so I see that a portion of your business
well some of it is existing furniture
you have an interesting side of this
business that's tied to design or
partnerships and collaborations can you
speak a little bit more about sort of
your arrangements with those designers
how you're sourcing them how they're
compensated and what that side of the
business looks like yes so we have not
to be clear we have not formally brought
on our first designer collaboration yet
for new pieces but the idea is that for
as far as the general resources we have
an existing supply chain of shippers
fabricators warehouse storage etc that
exists utilizing the resources from the
existing business and then as far as
bringing on new designers the main
initiative we kind of want to bring
forward is representing both a kind of
up-and-coming and desirable group of new
designers but also my diverse range of
designers so the idea is you know how do
we bring aboard people who you feel like
will be developing collectible pieces of
the future and we will use our own
in-house criteria and also make sure
that the royalties are ideally better
than what is typically offered in
industry I mean and we understand that
that's initially facing designers today
as well yeah and and what's really
interesting there also is that we can
have full control over these pieces and
document them extremely sort of
thoroughly so we can kind of communicate
how they're authentic how they're rare
and other unique and then using the data
that we've trained our machine learning
model on we can also come up with a
score for these new pieces and
anticipate that they might have a
particular investment value for someone
yeah and the kind of analogy today is
we're looking at the idea if you were to
build a company like an older Herman
Miller today what would they have done
and how would they have developed those
relationships so we're looking at you
know innovative up-and-coming designers
but also embedding technology trying to
make that streamline for consumers
direct-to-consumer and also using
in-house fabrication and fabricators so
that we don't need to charge for
third-party fabricators and so forth
wonderful and I believe we have time for
one more let's have Wendy
just heard the 60-second ding so you
have one minute
David Jeremy so fun so fun to see how
it's all gone
hey a quick question for you um so I'm
curious my first up
roadside antiques I think they you guys
need to be on there would be really
great to get them at the client I'm
curious about though the monetization of
this and where's how who's gonna be your
first customer and what are they gonna
pay you know ongoing subscription what's
the deal okay so there are a few
different business models the first one
is straightforward is we will be
approaching this as a business and
rigorously going through advertising
social media and so a lot of the initial
revenue will be coming from taking a
commission of the existing sales from
the previous business and that will help
fuel both along with hopefully with 15k
the new designer collaborations so the
initial would be the vintage pieces and
then immediately we'll start bringing in
designers bring about collaborations and
we hope within the first one to two
years the majority of our business will
then transition over to the new
collection so that we can focus on
emerging designers and new rare pieces
okay great well thank you all so much
thank you could seem verify up next
we've got Ark live thank you everybody
hello everyone my name is Alan and I'm
gonna be talking to you about Ark life
so as a quick introduction Ark live is a
video conferencing research tool that
helps historians conduct their research
internationally by providing live access
to non digitized documents
so we're basically like doctor on demand
but for research so most documents
aren't online and if if you really want
to learn about who an artist was what
they what they were like you'll look at
their notes we we on the left here we
have the Truvia man which came from
Leonardo's notes and usually if you want
to access these you're going to it says
on the right there underline likely that
you'll need to visit the research room
to actually see these notes most of them
aren't online and so your average
reading room looks something like this
you have hundreds of thousands of
documents stored this is
repository where they're readily
accessible and then long-term they're
put in depositories it's kind of like
Indiana Jones and the Ark of the
Covenant where they wheel the Ark into
that giant storage room this is an
archive this is basically what they're
like and they they measure usually they
don't even know how many documents there
are they measure them in cubic feet it's
the easiest way to do it because
nobody's ever counted them all and just
as an industry the document imaging is
about a 21 billion dollar market our
early accessible market we estimated 350
million we split that into true groups
which is the traveling researchers so
historians genealogists and then
research firms that's let's say you just
want to contract someone you can hire
them from there so on average less than
10% of archival documents are available
online and the reason for that is
usually archives can't afford the
digitisation costs if they're lucky
they'll get a grant to do it but then
they have to manage those documents
forever there's a recurring cost
associated with that
but also they have to worry about
copyrights usually documents acquired
within the last 30 to 40 years they
didn't expressly get those copyright
permissions to digitally distribute and
so as a result if somebody wants to
research it's filled with risk and
uncertainty now it is with long flights
that you have to deal with to physically
visit the archives especially
internationally most archives have
restricted hours so like 10:00 a.m. to
4:00 p.m. we actually heard one
researcher who was so worried she
wouldn't have enough time to conduct her
research that she opted to skip lunch
for five days to maximize her time in
the archive which is crazy and then you
have to they have to worry about the
copyright too and so combined with the
coronavirus now were we're starting to
see how valuable online accessibility
tools can be we can never go back to the
way things were before this and that
creates a really unique opportunity and
so we develop a new protocol that we
call control to remote visitation this
is our prototype on the left here which
allows you to work with a surrogate to
access documents in real time and this
circumnavigates the copyright
restrictions because this is a form of
live access we aren't making permanent
replications
so what we do normally it would cost
about eighteen hundred dollars to travel
say to Boston from the UK about sixty
bucks an hour we cut that in half
we charge $35 per hour for our service
which you can then take your travel
budget and use it to access different
geographic locations based on the
collections they have rather than
spending it all in one place so most
other companies focus on the public
domain or the the highest priority
documents that are available now which
is about 10% we focus on everything else
everything that you want to digitize but
it isn't worth it or else things that
will just they're just never going to be
digitized as far as our technical stack
goes we have the hover cam we these are
the workstations we issue for our
back-end we're using vmx call it's what
encodes the video and then we distribute
it using Twilio an online video platform
and we're going to be using googoo auto
ml later I'll talk a little bit about
that later excuse me how do we prevent
screenshots the video game industry
softness solve this a while ago
watermarking alpha channel layering is
what it's called so we don't have to
worry about that we can use this and
have an active ticker to track who is
you know doing that as far as
partnerships we already have our first
pilot with the Thoreau Institute at
Walden ponds
henry david thoreau hey yeah blow Walden
Pond in mass long-term we want a partner
with several other organizations and
then as far as corporate partnerships
we're looking at the Library of Congress
who legislation legislates copyrights as
well as Google and ancestry.com our
roadmap for the next three years pilot
in Boston ten archives spread throughout
the US and year two and then move
internationally later this is our team
my name is Alan Derrick is a slow and
fellow with MIT I went through the play
labs accelerator and that's archived
thank you very much thank you so much
our Clive I'd like to open it up for Q&A
from our judges now Alan if you could
staring please hold on there we go
let's see one we can do it I believe in
you
fairness perfect okay all right do we
have any initial questions mark I'm a
curator piece of piece of art do some
research in the archives do I have
enough information to tell your research
assistant just to do if you excuse the
expression the grunt work get to the
source material are you expecting the
researcher to do a certain amount of
interpretation on his or her own
conclusions so good question who's who's
still conducting the research we
function as an accessibility tool and so
the the surrogate that we have on-site
the research assistant their job is to
make sure that they can provide safe
access the the researcher themselves
being the subject matter they would be
the ones responsible for interpreting
what they're seeing and then determining
what to do next with their research in
the right direction yes so it would be
up to the researcher to request those
documents from storage to be pulled into
the reading room the and then we and
will help researchers do that we work
with the archivists to pull documents
that they need and we we specifically
help with the discovery process of
figuring out usually the discovery
process of going into an archive you're
looking for what sources you want to use
to cite or include in say a historical
novel or something like that I can maybe
give just a very quick specific example
to this my family is really big into
genealogical research and we recently
found a history of the list family at a
very small Ross County Historical
Library just outside of Columbus Ohio
the problem is due to copyright
restrictions they only have one physical
copy and on site and so the only way we
can access that is to physically go
there
and with a tool like archived archive
what we'd be able to actually do is call
in there one volunteer who's there from
8 a.m. to 6 p.m. would be able to
actually open up that resource and make
it available to us for a paid fee all
right let's hear from Mary next hi
thanks um I was curious how you
determine to the pay for the archives
assistant and if part of your
calculation had to do with the locations
major archives that people would be
using and the cost of living in those
locations hmm good question so we we
average the pay at $15 per hour
these are entry-level research positions
so all the money that would have been
going to the flights and hotels is
brought back in to create sustainable
jobs in the industry that may vary over
time one of the things that we're
looking at doing is increasing our
prices from $35 per hour up to $50 per
hour with add-ons such as OCR
translation you know or OCR tracking
real-time translation which is better
than doing research in person being able
to scan a page metadata extraction
because that's transformative in nature
we can save metadata and we'll just hand
that to the archives you know let's give
it for free and then yeah keyword
extraction so if you're researching John
Smith we can find you know if we find
John's Jonathan Smith we can say hey
this is 92% relevant to your research
topic which is where the Google auto ml
comes in and that will allow us to
dramatically increase our wages I mean
just to maybe follow up on that real
quick and there's no real
one-size-fits-all approach here so we're
gonna have to look closely at the
different archives we're working with
whether those are large-scale National
Museums
or whether we're looking at smaller more
local institutions which might not
necessarily have that same demand as
some of the the larger national archives
how about Wendy thanks guys interesting
really interesting curious about the
hardware that's going to be involved
actually on the site and then a training
that you're going to have to do
local folks sure want to see it um this
is our hardware right here a pond next
to me this is the hover cam solo eight
plus this is what we're using I was
going to use it as my video camera
every one the other is a I'm using it
right now so I've personally tested out
all the hardware that we're gonna need
it's it requires a pretty beefy laptop
for a workstation because you you're
encoding it and then you're distributing
it so the the hardware's so yes we will
be working directly with contractors so
issuing workstations to the assistants
who are going to be doing this another
option which we we might do depending on
how frequently it's used is assigning a
workstation per archive is another way
to do it we're still investigating that
on what's most efficient alright and
that is all the time we have for this
round of questions thank you so much Ark
live now I would like to welcome to the
virtual stage Carolyn and Natasha of
partner thank you all so much for
joining us today
routine partner I'm Carolyn and Natasha
we have all been moved by good art but
what happens when things go wrong the
city of Seoul spent 1.4 million dollars
commissioning renowned artists frank
stella for public sculpture and the
community was so offended by it
the city had to plant a ring of trees
around it unbelievable right this goes
to show that we don't always connect
with the art that we see in that
large-scale art is hard to create we're
not getting what we want out of the qu
million that we spend on public art each
year given white men constitute a
majority of local art rosters and
galleries these trends reveal that
aren't commissioning as we know it
prevents aren't seekers from finding art
creators as a consequence artwork in
public spaces doesn't represent local
neighborhoods in our cities
experiences a real-estate design manager
speaks to this consequence and looking
to create memorable and local
experiences for our customers
I found the process to be time-consuming
to manage as items were often lost in
translation between the development and
harvest world most critically this
extensive process did not always result
in rewarding art what I thought were my
singular frustrations
we're actually echoed throughout the
industry as we spoke further with both
sides it's inspiring to us that the
importance of art is affirmed by city
governments 360 of which mandate
developers spend 1% of construction
costs to provide public art partners
uses as an opportunity for local talent
to represent a neighborhood and increase
both real-estate and social value but
the benefits don't just end here
research shows that good art can create
destinations like now Milan increase
property values or even stimulate the
broader municipal economy partner aims
to harness the power of art culture and
performance team hands the urban
experience while increasing real-estate
value we celebrate local creative talent
and we do this by helping art seekers
discover connect with and commission the
most promising talent to move their
projects forward partner comes in with a
solution that connects buyers looking
for local large-scale art and sellers
who create it as a reimagined 21st
century public art gallery that
democratizes art commissioning buyers of
art looking to distinguish their
projects can virtually discover local
provided high-quality and community
oriented creators of art who know and
understand the neighborhoods they live
and create in buyers and sellers engage
in three features discover showcases
project proposals and portfolios
offering more opportunities for seekers
and creators to find each other the
connect function matches portfolios with
proposals and goals providing
collaborative communication of that
division the commission feature gives
fair pricing and clear steps to manage
contracts and deliverables we envision a
world where everyone knows art seekers
have direct and fast access to a broader
betted local talent pool a democratized
art commissioning process allows local
artists to help set parties apart which
then improves the public realm and leads
to placemaking with the purpose we're
competing against creative placemaking
agencies our consultants and art
commissioning platforms that often only
manage one portion of the process but
our competitive advantage empowers art
creators to take charge of their own
success through features like accessing
the wider vendor ecosystem curated
educational resources and a protected
marketplace that allows both sides to be
bold our business model operates a
freemium subscription and fee based
pricing art seeker is a subscription fee
to access creative talent through
commissioning and project execution
roadmap we hope to promote our seekers
and creators fools so that we can be in
10 cities at the end of the third year
so who are we we are a deeply invested
in partner because it marries our core
personal missions bringing together
empowering emerging artists curating
place making a responsible real estate
development given my experience as an
artist architect and real estate
developer I know the ins and outs of
complex art projects and how tricky that
can be for both sides to manage I'm a
policy wonk and startup lover
well-versed in bringing together
unlikely partnerships but also invested
in closing the racial wealth gap for
black and brown communities based on
experiences working in economic and
workforce development the competition
funding will help us establish our
virtual presence and demonstrate our
first project to scale up who will first
continue to compile our online database
of seekers and creators then design a
fair commissioning process and finally
pilot with a percent for our program
seeker during this time of great strife
and uncertainty many of us are turning
to art as an escape and form of healing
we a partner watch it play major role in
providing a reimagined gallery to help
current artists weather the storm and
ultimately enliven places through art
thank you so much for your time thank
you thank you both so much all right
let's hear from Iran please
Thanks this sounds interesting I guess a
couple of questions
one is you talked about focusing on
large-scale art and I was wondering if
is the kind of the main focus that you
guys have or is that sort of just the
beginning that you see for your business
and then the second question I have
actually has to do with you know what's
potentially interesting about your
businesses is connecting people across
different locations but at the same time
you're talking about the need for local
arts so that the local artists
understand the local scene and that's
how it works but that then actually
seems to limit you because then
basically what you're saying is for this
to work well you need local artists but
then the network effect is not that
interesting anymore because we're just
talking about local artists and in
localities you know so I was wondering
if you could address both of those
points sure so in terms of logical art I
think we were very deliberate in
addressing this because we really want
to be careful about not being associated
with smaller scale art which i think has
a lot more competition of what's already
being placed in the market and then also
recognizing that one of the big biggest
issues in art commissioning is funding
and so it was a very interesting journey
for us to realize that you know in one
hand artists that are always looking for
funding but on the other hand in the
real estate development world there is
all this funding that's been bookmarked
and so the project range can go from
50,000 on average to 2 million that's
being mandated to be spent per project
and then in terms of the local I think
that it's recognizing that in for
example the 500 artists that are given
for public art they do tend to be
national scale so we just want to
recognize that we want to be more
mindful about the artist process in
deliberating and communicating with the
community so that the art project that
is being created is more
to the neighborhood but then also
addressing the fact that there there's a
slight bit of a diversity issue in that
pool
wonderful next let's hear from ghee I
thank you for the presentation my
question it's a little similar to Ron's
I just want to develop that about the
local artists I think it's a great idea
to connect local artists to public art
and do that more there's a whole issue
of gentrification at a culture of
communities I live in Brooklyn for
instance and this is you know a constant
discussion about like how to represent
the communities they already lived in
certain neighborhoods they're being
replaced etcetera
I would how you see you know there's
there's something that's good for the
community not necessarily is gonna be
good for a real estate you know make
something more expensive and desirable
as an investment you know probably if
you put like one of your examples Yayoi
Kusama is like big pumpkin in front of
the building in Brooklyn it's gonna sell
for a higher price that if you get a
local artist which could potentially be
good for the neighborhood say how you
see that that issue yeah absolutely just
jumping in here that's a great question
that we've been thinking a lot about - I
think ideally on our platform as we're
bringing together local creators or like
make tree you know they don't have to be
necessarily like local or emerging but
right like as long as we're widening
that pool that is accessible to large
scale Art seekers that's really what
we're in the business for but also
specifically one of the features that
we're still sort of flushing out is
thinking through okay so if you have you
know a large scale project that you're
putting up as a proposal hopefully you
can get engaged several artists right
and so there might be five some locals
some not who are also sharing about
they're sort of like community and
social practice and that might actually
be a really great way to engage the
communities through art that helps with
you know the developers approval process
in in that so there's really we're
really hoping to hoping to open up an
opportunity for seekers to really engage
and meet and share their visions with
several artists through the process all
right let's hear from Phillip please
I just know the piece that really I
think is the most hard for me to
understand is you even mentioned the
other two cited marketplace which you
know how do you build credibility right
how do you find a way for both artists
to think like I can get my stuff here
and how do you get developers who are
used to going to a certain set of art
buyers if they trust to go to here
instead I think that that's the biggest
question and I didn't see anything in
the proposal but it really addresses
that this is our last answer
um so we are starting off with our
strategy kind of working with nonprofit
organizations and also working with
local developers so um we're really
excited to pilot with Sebastian art
school and in Somerville
so he's launching an development called
kala which is really centered around
community and art and has he has over
four hundred square feet of mural space
for artists to fill and so we want to be
partnering with like mission-driven
developers to start off with and we've
also we also have connections with great
nonprofit organizations like the
Dorchester art project and so if they
have artists and residents that we would
love to work with and feature in our
platforms so that's kind of our scale up
strategy yeah and then speaking to the
developer point of view I think that the
current practice is right now is
basically a developer will either choose
to spend a lot of money on in our
consultant or if their budget is about a
thousand dollars in less then they will
take it upon themselves to find artists
which means that they're not really you
know optimizing this opportunity and the
most interesting thing that we've heard
in all of our research interviews is the
fact that even when developers are
spending up to five hundred thousand
dollars in just consulting fees they've
always mentioned that at the very end
they were unsatisfied with the amount of
art that was catered to the local
community because I think that there's a
huge branding opportunity that's being
missed by developers because a lot of
them do you want to capture and show
that they have good faith towards the
community and if you're engaging artists
on the national scale you're not really
optimizing for the community buy-in so I
think there's there's definitely a mix
that needs to be had in how you
structure your are and where you want to
be placing it but there definitely is a
lack on the the local talent right now
all right thank you so much partner next
up I would like to welcome elements hi
everyone I'm Maria Michael
we are team elements elements is
designed learning in a box
elements unlocks the full potential of
every student our kids teach creative
thinking to students ages 10 to 14
preparing them for the emerging jobs and
challenges of the 21st century and
developing their human skills in the age
of automation parents and teachers
increasingly acknowledge the value of
design education in the short term they
see students build fundamental design
skills and engage in project-based
learning schools see higher graduation
rates and improved test scores in the
long term whether students become
designers or anything else they build
creative problem-solving skills they
build a lifelong appreciation of design
and they hone their spatial and
iterative thinking skills despite all
that arts education in the US has been
on a steady decline as of 2008 only
about a quarter of graduating seniors
reported having any access to a visual
arts education and outside of public
school systems access to design
education is expensive and exclusive
current options like university
pre-college programs or a specialized
creative art school can cost about two
thousand dollars for only a two week
course that's why we've come up with
elements our kids teach different
elements of design such as deployable
structures stop-motion and pattern
design through open and the challenges
elements has a three-part value
proposition designed for all elements
brings design thinking project-based
learning and creative problem-solving to
future creatives future professionals
and future everything else tactile
learning elements offers physical
learning materials and tactile design
challenges per twith an online platforms
for students to share the creative work
and finally elements is designed to
develop the uniquely human skills of the
21st century professional so why us we
believe that we're uniquely suited for
this venture and we are really motivated
about this issue we truly believe that
everyone should have access to design
education we will implement our own
design Ticino
and techniques into the logic of the
game our adventure actually began as a
partnership where both Michael and I
were looking at experimental teaching
methods and together we run teaching
seminars for MIT students that original
collaboration grew into our current
venture so elements has three cultural
touchstones the first element is
generous serious design education
demands and openness to outside voices
and unorthodox ideas the second elements
is approachable design is often
considered in lead or snobby we try to
defy those stereotypes both in access
and our attitude and third elements is
experimental our commitment to
experimentation applies to our teaching
practices our design practices and our
venture at large so to those ends we've
assembled a team of mentors both within
MIT and in the broader community
groping us grow the venture and maintain
those values moving forward so back to
the kids and a few of the prototypes
were working on this is the curriculum
for color material and pigment
formulation with this a student would go
out into their local gather a series of
objects and then have the resources and
instructions to transform those objects
into workable paints and pigments
another prototype here that looked at
rule base drawing we tested in the fall
with MIT a mark students and then again
over the winter at MIT splash with
junior high and high school students
from the area okay so now let's have a
look at the market the u.s. toy market
averages over 20 billion dollars per
year with building sets gains and arts
and crafts accounting for 25% of that
toto our research shows that there is a
trend in education of products shifting
away from creative subjects to science
and engineering subjects by junior high
and high school leaving older students
without access to creative curriculum so
that's one minute warning so that's
where we see elements fitting in we
believe we will occupy this gap in the
market and we believe that design
learning and creative thinking should be
encouraged at all ages that's why our
products offer creative curriculum to an
age group where these subjects are being
phased out so elements will launch as a
direct
consumer online sales company it will be
targeting middle school students and
their parents and families as our
beachhead market this is a sweet spot
for us because junior high students are
still exploring a variety of subjects
their parents are highly involved and
they're not yet fixated on college
admissions in years two and three of the
venture we plan to expand our market and
offer wholesale curriculum to public
schools and corporate teams so with the
help of mi t--'s creative arts
competition we'll develop our initial
line of six curriculum kits anticipating
a monthly subscription model in the
future will establish partnerships with
manufacturers and begin shifting our
production out of house and we'll
finalize our at-home prototype kits and
our online sharing platform for a soft
launch this summer and finally what is
our vision
well we imagine a society which supports
future generations of entrepreneurs
designers makers and innovators and
where access to design education is
available to all regardless of
background or economic status thank you
thank you all right thank you so so much
and let us turn to our esteemed panel
let's see Iran cool thanks for the
presentation it looks super cool and
probably really fun to use my question
is really about how you plan to get this
out there and market it this seems like
a consumer plate to me you said that
you're not playing to target schools
initially and and so if you're going
directly after sort of parents and
junior high school kids how do you
compete with the you know billions of
marketing dollars that are already going
out there by all the major companies
it's true it's a real challenge for us
we have a few strategies to get started
the first is to begin locally and use
public institutions like libraries as a
place to launch these gained publicity
one-on-one in-person with people and
then there's specific kind of user
segments that we're looking at like the
homeschool community which is very very
plugged in they have their own kind of
culture in a sense and so we're
targeting those individuals subsets of
customers and we're gonna try to market
to them individually but I would say the
kind of grassroots on the ground in
library
in communities and after-school centers
that's that's how we kind of get the
publicity that we think people will
react to all right Josh next
presentation and of course it's a it's a
it's an interesting time and a good time
for a product like this you spoke a bit
about the market and it seems clear
you're you're you know you're delivering
some some real value here in these kits
I'm wondering if you have a sense of
sort of costs involved in all these
various kits the production of them kind
of where your profit margins might lie
in a project like this given that it's
so physical and they're shipping involve
etcetera right yeah I'll take this one
yeah we've been looking at costs and
yeah we we agree that we're like kind of
like a very traditional startup in that
sense because we like our profits will
be directed from the product and not so
much from like I know like platform or
something like that so we have been
considering that and we've also been
looking into partnering with art
supplies companies so that we so that we
get everything at a discounted price but
really the value where we see adding
value to the to our products is the
challenges that we'll be implementing in
there so our idea is to have open-ended
challenges so that each student develops
a completely different thing out of
whichever kid they they they pick so no
two final products will be the same so I
think the value in our product would
really be in those in those prompts and
challenges that will be coming and not
so much from so I think we will be able
to make profits on that all right Wendy
great thank you questions for you it's
one thing for you to get the kit in the
mail it's another thing to actually get
the kids to open it up and do it
wondering what's gonna make it that you
get them to actually engage is there a
social media aspect take your picture on
Instagram what's that whole integration
sure so although this is mostly a
physical product
the one digital component we have that
we think is really important is an
online platform for students to post
images of their work see what other
students have made with the same
curriculum or with other curriculum and
I think all of us who are engaged in any
kind of studio practice or education
right now we're seeing how valuable
studio culture and seeing one another in
the space actually is so we know that
the the small digital this fall digital
component of our venture has to do that
and basically produce studio culture
online in a way that's distributed and
would allow people across the country to
see one another's work all right II
thank you that sounds that sounds really
interesting I'm curious I wish the
presentation had a little bit more
detail what goes inside the box
I think that's potentially something
that sounds really fun I think people
would like to play some icy a little kit
of stop-motion there which is something
that I do so I'm curious like how would
you approach someone to learn to do
something like that and you know like
make it fun but also you know like
open-ended enough to be creative but
clear enough to explain people so like I
would like to know more about it to me
it's really all about what's in the box
and how are you gonna how are we gonna
do that I don't think you're gonna have
like a quick explanation for that so
more of a comment about the presentation
my last response thank you so much yeah
we've been we've actually been
developing three of those products that
will be launching and the common theme
amongst all of them is that it will have
different three different prompts and
the first one it will be like scaffold a
learning so the first one will be very
straightforward teaching the student the
basic skills the second one we will
build the student will build build up on
those skills that were already in
challenge one and there they will be
able to be a bit more creative and then
the third one will be the final will be
completely open-ended using the skills
that they've already developed in the
other challenges and just
and the idea from that came from both
Michael and I have been teaching and I'm
actually currently doing a teaching
certificate program at MIT and so we're
using we're implementing all of those
teaching techniques that we well that
we've been using and that we're
currently learning as well into the kids
so we're really going to try to scaffold
that learning so that the final thing
that we will be able to do in the kid
will be completely yeah could I
completely personal and individual to
each student all right thank you so much
key elements up next we've got material
futures lab hi there so if we look
around the Xoom call and now that we're
at home as well in our closets we can
quickly determine that we all wear a lot
of colored clothing and that's awesome
because colored clothing makes us feel
and look great and actually the practice
of coloring textiles has been around for
thousands of years and is a culturally
significant practice the Navajo tribe
for instance in the United States
creates these beautiful weaving charts
such as the one you see on screen to
document and keep track of the plant
matter that they use to create their
colored dye stuffs but unfortunately a
lot of these practices are only capable
to be done on a small scale and they're
not easily scalable so we end up looking
at a lot of images like this when we
think of the textile industry
unfortunately the textile industry is
actually responsible for 20% of global
water pollution and is the second most
polluting industry after the oil
industry and so the current method of
coloring fabrics involves using
synthetic dyes and these are often
treated with toxic chemicals and heavy
metals they do not decompose and so that
means the same dye stuffs that were used
to color fabrics 150 years ago are still
persisting in our oils in our soils
rather and in our waterways and
unfortunately their plant dye
counterparts are actually not much
better plants are incredibly resource
intensive intensive they require acres
of
years of growing time and several
hundred leaders watered to grow and in
fact indigo farmers in the United States
have reported that it requires them to
grow up 13 acres of indigo dye plants to
color just one acre of cotton fiber and
so to put the global problem into
perspective the total market size of
dyes and pigments manufacturing is
estimated at forty nine billion dollars
and is growing at five percent per year
due to sustainable innovation we see the
textile industry specifically starting
to respond to these changes to promote
more sustainable products and processes
due to increasing regulations on
wastewater treatment and consumer
preferences for environmentally friendly
processes at material futures lab we
have developed a process which turns
microorganisms into miniature dye
factories we are able to produce really
brightly colored pigments such as the
purple blue one you see on screen but
don't fade due to light or in washing we
have proven our process at the bench
scale and we are now beginning to scale
our production process some of the key
benefits of this approach to producing
pigments is that our powders can be
easily substituted for synthetic
pigments that are used currently we can
control our growing conditions to ensure
high yields and consistent color and we
can scale our process using existing
manufacturing to meet global demand we
aim to restore the tradition of natural
dyeing on a large scale by leveraging
biotechnology and process engineering we
see our technology actually translating
across multiple scales despite the work
that we're doing being mainly at the
scale of a cell
this type of sustainable production
actually results in cleaner and safer
conditions of the dye house as well we
promote a more sustainable economy and
global market so we are really excited
actually to be announcing our our
partnership with lululemon athletica
we've been in contact with them for a
while and even throughout the
coronavirus era we're going to be
applying our technology to color
Berek square and they're leggings
they're an incredible partner they're
leaders for sustainable fashion and
they're reshaping the fashion industry
to adopt more sustainable technology and
we're privileged and humbled to have
their support Joe and myself bring a
wealth of experience in couture fashion
sustainable design including textile
design and metabolic engineering
we're also supported by amazing mentors
such as dr. Valerie ward she is by
training a bioprocess quencher minute is
supporting our scale-up process Ethan is
also an artist by training and involved
with the Sloan School at MIT he has been
providing us with mentorship on how to
build out our arts based technology
actually into a sustainable business
model so we plan to use the $15,000 I
think from the MIT creative arts
competition I should have filed a patent
on our process and to start scaling our
manufacturing to meet demand so that
material futures are we believe in a
world that's designed with and for
nature and we hope to bring this
technology to your closets and zoom
calls very soon thanks so much and we
will now take your questions and your
comments Thanks all right Thank You iris
and let us turn Mary let's hear from you
please thank you yes I this is a really
exciting product an idea that I was
wondering if you could just talk a
little bit more about how this works I
don't really have a good understanding
of how you're using microorganisms to
create dyes yet from your presentation
yeah so I guess in the kind of short way
to explain it
you know microorganisms produce a number
of compounds and one of them in our case
is pigments and so we're able to
leverage the processing power of
microorganisms to produce our pigments
you've developed an environmentally
friendly process of actually harnessing
those pigments and powder rising them
and it's the pigment powders that were
actually selling
alright next mark to your question I'm
sorry okay here you hear me now yep you
can all are you on government regulation
yeah so huge huge push towards our
technology it's actually a lot of
pigment manufacturing has a lot of
regulation around it and so in our case
we're using like a lot of sustainable
chemistry and nothing is against the
processes of like heavy metals or
anything like that and so that's
actually a huge incentive for for
companies like Lululemon to switch to
our sort of product all right kill it
first I really I think there's a huge I
love how you've identified the issues
with the kind of market it's it's this
is a big problem so there's a lot of you
know I love to see how you're bringing
innovation to it I think that the the
the the piece that's again sort of like
missing for me is you know I in the fact
that you've already started to answer
and that you've already gotten a sort of
this pre-commercial relationship with
lemon but what is the business model
like you're selling pigments I mean are
how are you going to scale that
production if you're at the bench level
now like I you know there's part of
that's my big question to actually just
convert our process and scale that and
then we're gonna be doing some
post-processing in our labs and then B
and then B I'm shipping that directly to
our customers so our customers range
from end users like brands Lululemon who
work up their supply chains they also
can include companies like paint
manufacturers artist paints plastics
manufacturers and we're in contact with
a bunch of those companies wonderful
Wendy oh you can
I was just thinking about one of the
other uses for this I'm like why did you
pick the clothing industry as opposed to
something that might be a little easier
to get into so yeah we see that like
paints and and plastics they definitely
have a use for these they're less
consumer facing and they're
manufacturing and so we think that
environmentally and sustainably we want
to be promoting that that message and so
textiles is a really great way to do
that alright and I think I have time for
one more from Iran cool so can you
actually make all the colors yeah so so
we're producing like a blue purple
pigment right now and we're also looking
at red the idea is to go try chromatic
so that we can mix okay but it's so
that's not a concern right like it I
imagine that the the buyers are gonna
want to have a large palette of colors
you know that's probably what they're
used to and so but so that's not like a
technical challenge for you as well in
our conversations
we hear a lot that blue and red pigments
tend to be the most toxic and so those
are actually the ones if we can produce
those they provide a really good
alternative if there's there's a number
of yellow and kind of orange pigments
like tumeric and things like that which
are manufactured for food processing so
being able to produce blue pigments for
instance that are stable to heat and
light or has a value mm-hmm alright
wonderful thank you for that I think at
this point we will now move on last but
not least to team on makes good
sustainability and natural materials in
the production art production process
the idea originated 10 years ago when I
started experimenting with sustainable
materials while working with some of the
most influential artists from the world
the practices made a huge impact on my
thought process and I tried to convert
it into this company sustainability plus
art is a multi-faceted concept that
being followed across several cultures
in the world and million
are leading this race currently our
primary research proves the tens of
artists go on to really work with
sustainable materials and are highly
inclined toward sustainability the
online art sales of a market of 4.6
billion dollars and this decimal product
sales of 150 billion dollars that just
just goes on to prove that this
sustainability is on a rapid rise so the
whole world is moving towards
sustainability the online art markets
are rising and the consumer section is
growing rapidly but this market is
currently very segmented and it Nene
it's a huge reconnection and a bridge
and that's where we come in we lie at
the intersection of the sustainability
market the art industry and the rising
consumer section we are bridging the gap
between sustainability and the art
industry by connecting sustainable
locally sourced materials and those
material producers this is our
production strategy an artist uploads
their work uploads a work on our
platform we produce it using recycled
paper and recycled ink then we use the
city specific metal or bamboo or wooden
frame to could produce it and then be
distributed to the customer or our
scaling strategy is simple we are only
going to scale up City wise based on the
art awareness ease of production and
delivery and sustainability
consciousness of the cities and we are
going to going to deliver only within
the city premises to avoid shipping and
keeping the carbon footprint minimal we
have started operations in to our
conscious global cities New York and
Bombay and our logistics proof our
research proves that they are totally
logistic logistically suitable for our
work
proposition is multifold they are
encouraging a global community of
artists across the world to come
together here fostering a combination of
local local plus global intercultural
fusion we are cultivating environmental
consciousness we are providing business
opportunities to emerging an individual
artists across the world and we are
enhancing the local an art and craft and
boosting the local economy of the cities
we are going to partner with artists
material suppliers local craftspeople
delivery vendors as well as the local
printing studios who will give us the
space and let us do the work in their
Studios a remaining model comprises of
the royalty set by the artists and our
production cost and we are going to
charge fifteen percent of the total cost
this is a hypothesis customer scenario
in which a Japanese artist puts her work
on our platform a bomb base a Bombay
girl like the work and orders it on on
and make our in-house craftsmen Ravi
Prince the Japanese art on old Indian
devotee cloth add with natural pigment
ancient print technique and then the
artwork is delivered to Ma three she'd
love the artwork framed with vernacular
Indian material and the Japanese art we
have already registered several 50 plus
registrations from all over the world
and 50 plus high quality artworks are
there on our website already which you
can check on our website they're being
supported by MIT sandbox Innovation Fund
and the MIT innovation initiative and of
course MIT creative arts competition the
images that you see in the background
are all received are all sent by the
artists from around the world with the
15k we are going to test the physical
product and this money will also help us
in the outreach we are researching about
the the competitive analysis and we
figured that the business model of the
current players does not deal with
sustainability at all and be lie
somewhere between players like Etsy and
frame bridge and we provide a
sustainable or alternative to them a
team comprises of professional artists
financial experts technical experts and
we've all been working together for
several years I am an architecture
student here at MIT and I recently
headed the MIT Energy Initiative which
was the MIT
student rain initiative in India a team
also comprises of professors and
advisors who have been working in the
art sector for several years in addition
to the domain-name technical expertise
provided by the MIT sandbox and Arts at
MIT we've been partnering with hundreds
of several local artists in India and
the US and they're very happy to team up
with us
we're also teaming up with prospective
influencers Axela McCartney Bobby Sager
and these people are very happy to to be
involved in our project we have
conducted several workshops related to
local material use this recent one was
in Taipei in which we asked the people
to go in in their city and drink local
materials and we were trying to
understand their the relationship and
their their idea about local materials
one minute these are our future plans in
the next phase we are going to penetrate
into the under-privileged region regions
to reach out the art is there they're
going to use eco-friendly transportation
like a bikes and bicycles and local
public transportation they are going to
partner with art galleries museums and
art festivals and the analysis of the
world in the phase 3 we are going to
expand into cities which put environment
first for example Copenhagen and
Amsterdam we are going to launch an
option on our website in which the
artists will get much more exposure we
are going to use technology to review
the artwork so that we maintain high
quality work on our website and finally
we are going to build an institution
around the core idea of anak that
matches art in sustainability
so if overall we are setting the art
industry as an example in the move
towards sustainability which will
inspire other industries to move towards
a sustainable future thank you thank you
so much
let's get right into some questions I
see that Josh has his hand up
I thank you for the presentation in in
viewing your slides as a customer I want
to know a bit more about the quality I
can expect I'm curious to know I didn't
see any specific physical prototypes
could you speak a little bit more about
the quality of the bamboo frames the
brightness of the inks the materials and
what a customer can expect on that level
yeah so that that is explained by our
partnerships and they've been doing with
several organizations who are working
with with these materials in India and
in the u.s. right now we don't have a
physical prototype to show you but our
partnerships show that you know these
people have been working on that and we
can produce a high quality product with
the with the help of these experienced
stakeholders all right how about Marc
make a very particular painting sorry me
Marc can you please repeat that
number of copy he would make for a given
painting no it totally depends on the
artist and it's not just paintings it's
paintings photographs digital artwork
illustrations any kind of visual art so
the vision would probably not be a
secondary market yeah so our business
model actually provides transparency and
uniqueness in which the artist is
allowed to do their own business on the
side and our our model will actually
enhance their existing business by using
the sustainability narrator all right
let's hear from Wendy next
you
oh my you how are you sorry about Lily
windy great and great hey quick question
how are you gonna bet your artist are
you sorry can you come again
how will you bet your artist how you
decide who is who's the lucky one to get
to upload their artwork yeah so as you
as I said we have professional artists
in our team and we will be doing a
careful curation of the artwork that we
receive and we have already if you go to
our website you will see a bunch of
artworks which you have already curated
input on the website and we took several
days to you know choose the best
artworks and also we are reading the
background of the artist their
experience in the industry and their
relevance to our our product wonderful
thank you let's have a question from
Philip next please
I so I mean see your your drive for
sustainability as a differentiator the
product as I see it is a on demand
poster printing service with a custom
frame is that correct
no that's not actually true if you look
at your value proposition can you see my
slide no can you see my screen
you're not screen-sharing because we've
stopped screen sharing the deliberation
portion for the Q&A portion yeah so I
think that's a very good question and I
would like to make it clear that it's
not just a business of selling art we
are trying to connect local and global
artists together by our venture so for
example if you are an artist sitting
here in the US you publish your work in
our platform and a person in India likes
it they buy it and be without with a
local partners produce it using
sustainable materials and with the help
of the local crafts Indian crafts we're
going to make it so it's a bridge of
different in art cultures together
that's the primary value proposition
it's not just gives gives money or
business opportunity opportunity to the
are but also boost the local economy and
local craft
all right let's hear from B
you
you're muted gay
II right so just like spending on
Philips question you're you're gonna be
a curator of those artists so artists
are gonna be invited to participate in
this whole environment that you're
creating that has the produced as the
the the copies of the work and etc so
you're gonna have like all that you're
gonna do like this some management and
curation of the artists not just produce
the copies yeah exactly
so we are not just looking at artworks
we are also looking at the artist and
his you know overall overall theme his
works is experienced and the kind of
artwork is provably reduces and then we
are going to also talk with the local
partners our craft craftsmen if they if
they're actually you know if these
artworks are relevant to to what they
feel you know what they believe in so
it's a partnership with local craftsmen
as well as the artists okay so just to
be clear like if I'm not part of this
and I want to print my own artwork in
sustainable ink and and frame it
sustainably I know that stuff I'm not
gonna be allowed
you're not going to provide that service
to third parties just for your own
artists no why not I mean you can
definitely reach out to us there's a
there's a form in our website if you
fill that form and you up late upload
your work we reach your work right now
or I mean right away and then we see if
you fulfill our conditions then we'll
definitely put your work on our website
so it's transparent and it's open to
everyone the only things we are we are
considering is that the artworks should
not incite violence and you know it
should not provide proof and should not
give anti anti sustainable ideas to the
audience all right thank you so much
team unmake thank you all for your
wonderful pitches it was really I do
yeah thank you
oh no the judges will be departing for
approximately 45 minutes of deliberation
now I invite you to submit questions to
our teams and enjoy some conversation
about these pitches that you've just
heard
we'll begin with questions that were
submitted via the Q&A box and then we'll
be allowing attendees to be unmuted for
the rest of the conversational portion
of the webinar if there's time for such
a thing
following some QA will be holding the
audience choice voting so please cast a
vote to determine who will win a $500
prize and then we'll hear an update from
our 2019 15k winning team mark Adams
will be here from teach to learn to give
you an update about all the exciting
things that they've done since they won
the 15k and I hope you enjoy the
conversation the voting and the update
and we'll return shortly for our finale
to reveal this year's winners thank you
all so much see you soon hi everyone so
the first submitted question was for arc
life the equation was this sounds like a
really cool startup that fills a niche
untapped market he's wondering how the
partnerships are going and if you have
any feedback on the product so far arc
left turn to take that part partnerships
were going well until the corona virus
hit that we've it's been rocky over the
past few months because a lot of
archives have just completely shut down
we we've been talking with MIT the the
main MIT archives and the icon
documentation center here we're looking
to get into Harvard we've we've been
prioritizing a lot of specifically in
Boston a lot of larger ones after we
focus on Boston we'll probably head to
New York next just because it's like a
four-hour drive there so that's pretty
good and then we'll be focusing all the
major cities probably on the west coast
like LA San Francisco feel free oh sorry
Susan I was just gonna say you know we
see a lot of potential to in the private
sector to partner to sector enterprises
specifically with with an ancestry.com
which is a 650 million dollar business
we see a lot of opportunity there they
have
open access to public records but when
it comes to actual archival access those
are restricted and we see partnership
opportunities with them to get our
product out there through our
subscription model thank you
just for the audience feel free to
submit any questions into the Q&A or you
can raise your hands and we can put you
on video I see we just had one come in
for our materials futures lab are you
considering working with small artists
designers hand makers who are big
supporters of sustainability in textiles
right now we're very interested actually
to start producing at a large enough
quantity that we can be you know
creating enough supply we're definitely
interested in partnership as well so if
you are interested yeah you can send us
an email or we're happy to get in touch
right
I'm suggested of some general questions
for everybody um what has been the most
enjoyable aspect of this composition I
know it's been sort of a long ride this
year and a lot of differences obviously
in the last couple of months what's been
the most enjoyable part of the
competition so far
doesn't answer that okay go for it yeah
so I think what was really interesting
particularly both precoded times when
we're able to all be together was the
kind of mentorship sessions and then
also taking that on to mentor Lee
digitally but it was a really
interesting way of allowing all of the
groups to engage and learn from one
another and kind of grow their pitches
and business development regardless of
whether you were a finalist or not so I
thought there's opportunities for
fantastic is that having an opportunity
for all of us Thanks
did you want to else want to field that
one okay great so a question for unmake
our artist allowed to make sustainable
copies of art works through unmake yes
definitely they're allowed to make
sustainable copies of their yeah for
partner do you have any partnerships
that you've already established or
interest that you've seen from real
estate developers would you seek out
partnerships from city governments as
well absolutely and we would love to
partner with Boston City of Boston they
just started a really awesome percent
for program that they're kind of testing
out in piloting right now and also in
San Francisco that's where Natasha and I
are currently based in the chuco's and
we first met
Sebastian who's building out this really
awesome adaptive reuse community in near
Davis Square and it's just we just like
really want to be aligned with kind of
developers where artists themselves are
really care about social impact and our
very mission driven so we're really
going after those developers and have
been in a lot of great conversations
with them Thanks
another question for unmake as an artist
if I send you something depending on
what materials are used at every level
the makers choices will produce
different results some that I might not
like will there be a proofing process
for both the artists and the buyers yeah
so our process involves the
collaboration of both the participating
artists as well as the craftsmen and God
whatever material we produce whatever
the final product is is it involves both
the artist as well as the craftsman and
if the artist does not want a particular
kind of craft attached to their artwork
they're free to do to tell us that
what's been the most important lesson
that any of the teams have learned
throughout the process I know for many
of you it's been a very long process and
some shorter but are there any sort of a
major landmarks that I felt like big
discoveries learned tricky question I'm
sure sorry verify did you have an answer
cohort yeah I mean I think it's this was
a great opportunity to really like dive
into for instance a business plan and so
having the time and accountability to
devote to looking at a business plan and
seeing critiques seeing how relevant and
kind of acute the feedback was from
those that we received feedback from and
so you know it's always it's interesting
when you're speculating okay what's your
rep and you're gonna be in and all this
stuff but at least me what I have the
opportunity to look through it
investigate speculate and trying to be
as accurate and rigorous as possible
thank you question came in for a partner
um juvenile ocol artists capable or
eager to work at the public art scale
yeah idea here is that you know some
folks might not realize that they're
perfect for public art maybe like they
work with fabric or you know other
materials that aren't 2d or 3d
in the same way that large-scale art is
but that they've never really realized
their potential that way and so because
we're really leaning on reaching out to
nonprofit arts organizations that have a
lot of artists in residence we're really
hoping that folks at these nonprofits
can kind of be curating an introducing
artist to sort of these new ideas
because they really know their artists
they're artists pool as well are you
picturing kind of having opportunities
for both you know physically smaller
scale public art as opposed to just sort
of gigantic murals and the kind of thing
because I think that's one of the one of
the questions is that if you're not a
muralist or a sculptor is there a we
definitely want to address the fact that
art doesn't have to just be murals
especially for the public art realm it's
really interesting to hear what the
different regulations are for example in
Massachusetts Massachusetts public art
can only be you know sculptural and 3d
and then in California public
or the extended towards live
performances and exhibitions and words
speech so we really want to expand on
what art is and then in terms of the the
previous question in terms of the number
of artists as part of our business plan
we want to create a curated experience
so that every single city we would only
be representing about 60 artists so we
do want to be mindful about diluting the
pool thank you a couple more questions
for unmake one just how the name came
about and also if you have a economic
breakdown for sort of each section of
the process so right now as as I
explained in the slide that we have
calculated the the production cost based
on the material price plus the and the
price of the of the of the construction
that includes the labor cost as well as
the cost of printing and in New York
it's around fifty eight dollars and in
Bombay it's around twenty five dollars
does that answer your question
Oh safer the question answer right back
and how did the name come about yeah the
name it it basically comes from the
process of of you know using recycled
materials because everything that has
made creates a carbon footprint and
since we are only using recycled and
sustainable materials we are unmaking
that process that's why we are called
unmake thank you so much I think one of
the most valuable parts from an outside
perspective before this competition is
the great access that you will have to a
really wide variety of mentors and and
some of the judges and and that that
feedback process what's been some of the
most useful advice that you've gotten
from mentors throughout this our life or
did you want to answer that one
yeah sure I'm happy - yeah the mentor
resources were great I think they really
forced us to ask how we can leverage our
technology to also gain access to
copyrighted materials so that we're not
simply putting in work stations but
actually gaining access to those
copyrights there's a lot of potential
future revenue that could be derived if
we can do so so that was certainly
something that's that's forced us to
rethink about how we move forward did
any of the other teams have really
useful feedback to kind of help shape
how their presentations have developed
over the course of the year sure I can
respond to that quickly I mean both
Maria and I we don't come from business
backgrounds we're architects by training
so in a sense this was our first time
trying to develop a business plan and
all the things that are associated with
that so I would say the mentors really
kind of lasered in on all of our blind
spots and showed us what we if the
questions we didn't even know to ask so
that by the end of this we were able to
kind of sharpen the idea and get
somewhere hopefully some somewhat
convincing that's great thank you
I rare if I had you wanted to answer
that one sure I was just gonna say that
um it's been really nice to kind of work
through with our mentors and with with
other peers kind of the story that we're
telling and kind of making sure that
sort of her passion kind of comes across
because her venture is kind of so
personal to us as as everyone says I'm
so really telling a story has been
something that we've loved working on
thank you so much one question came in
for material futures what sort of
performance testing have you performed
on your biologically produced pigments
do they bleach in the Sun will they
withstand washing at high temperatures
sorry no sorry I think we just typed an
answer yes okay great you beat me to it
that's great Oh are there any
differences between the performance and
utility of these pigments and other
commercial industrial made ones that you
found so far yeah so of course like
synthetic pigments they're made often
with metals heavy metals and and often
have very very strong fastness that's
kind of what they've been designed to do
or specific performance attributes and
so our pigments are organic pigments so
by nature they're biodegradable and
fully organic so their lifespan is
likely not going to be as long we have
had really good results for life
fastness and washing up to temperatures
of 120 degrees so far but we're gonna be
rigorously testing over the next couple
of months to really determine exactly
what what specs we have so yeah
hopefully we'll be able to determine
that I imagine with Lululemon you'll get
a pretty good crash course durable they
are for extreme use one more question
for unmake how do you foresee the art
industry setting the sustainability
narrative I'm not sure if I understood
the question but whatever I understood
from that I can I can answer we we can
see that the art industry right now it's
it's basically basically quite
fragmented there is a and lays a whole
sustainability area in the art industry
which has not yet been leveraged enough
and the artists they really want to work
with sustainable materials that's that
that we got to know with our interviews
and also with the research and if we you
know let them use the sustainable
materials and also make profit out of it
that's that's gonna make a change in the
industry great thank you so much um I
think unless anyone has any other
questions from the audience we will move
forward with the audience choice voting
which is very exciting
so our colleague Donna will put up a
slide just so everyone can kind of
remember who they're voting for and I
will start the poll now will give about
five minutes for everyone to vote and
we'll come back with a quick video from
last year's 15k and then teach to learns
presentations update so please feel free
to vote for your audience choice now
each team will have five minutes to
pitch everybody knows that they will
then have five minutes for questions and
answers after their pitch the 15k
creative arts competition is for student
arts focused businesses so this is an
area of on it's arts entrepreneurship
that tends to mix the Arts and
Technology and Sciences up in very
interesting ways well first of all I
think MIT is just an incredibly creative
place there are so many creative people
here I remember as a student just
thinking that in a sense
art was everywhere as a woman of color
and as the citizens of desert I have
some concerns
the parameter for applying is really
just to have an idea even if you're a
solo entrepreneur because after you
apply there are six weeks of mentoring
and networking and workshops so that at
the end of April that live pitch day you
have a strong business plan you've
considered your market you considered
your past market you considered your
team gear value prop and all of the
other things that an important business
has the mentorship component really
helped us rethink some of our the way
we're presenting our ideas and even some
of our business model questions I think
the most important thing is not the
Reno's
the prophecy arena
we're seeing a lot of technological
disruption in the arts and MIT being a
leader in technology it just needs to be
involved in in supporting the arts from
a technological perspective Thank You
Danna and now we have the pleasure and
privilege of hearing from Mark Adams
from teach to learn thanks Susan can you
hear me yes do something great I'm gonna
go ahead and share my screen make sure I
get that audio in there it's a really a
pleasure to be here joining you today on
zoom though we wish we could be there in
person and a beautiful venue we were
last year but maybe next year hopefully
I'm here to give you a little bit of an
update on teach to learn and I hope that
you'll let me know if you can't see this
but it seems to learn is a global arts
education network and really the core of
what we do is using music as a
foundation for building personal
relationships and a truly online
community and our goal is is really to
empower our people to share what they
know and love I'm going to quickly show
a video here
hi my name is Sammy Stephen I'm from
East River man usually residing in
Brooklyn New York right now camping out
and care about bellyache
I sing and play that a few and when I
teach I learned hi my name is ally :
Argentina
my name's akhom and I'm from Iraq Mosul
hi my name is Tatiana from Argentina
hi I'm Camille I live in Auckland New
Zealand
I play the oboe and when I teach I
learned
[Music]
[Music]
okay looks like we have some trouble
with the video Susan you couldn't see
that right couldn't see I could hear it
Oh annoying and it's playing right now
what we can if there's a link to it
anywhere we can definitely put that in
the in the chat as well and have people
kind of view it on YouTube and come back
if that's easier or yeah okay let me
kill that one and we can figure out how
to do that after but okay no doubt that
there was going to be some technical
challenges to doing this but the purpose
of that video is just to give you a
little bit of a personal connection and
a face-to-face with a few of our fellows
from our fellowship program but some of
the high level stats of where teach
learn is we've been around for about
four years now and in that time we've
had over 250 participants in 20
countries around the world and you know
all together they've connected for more
than a thousand hours which is pretty
amazing when you think about where we
started from four years back our
programs started out of really just a
single one of the this mentorship
program and you can think of our
programs in two buckets one to one and
one to many
so when we would when you should learn
just started when our co-founder is
Derek and and Bob started making matches
of people playing similar instruments
with similar similar musical interests
between musicians all around the world
that was our mentorship program that was
a chance for especially students in
areas where there wasn't access to great
musical resources to connect with
musicians all around the world for
lessons and and also out of that
cultural exchange and a lot of
interesting things and came from those
conversations and the demand for that
was was really impressively high more
than more than we anticipated and that's
sort of where we were when we came into
the 15k competition with that that
mentorship program had been
for a couple years and we were thinking
about how do we take this to sort of the
next level and how do we grow this out
what programs do we add and that's from
that so we've developed another
one-to-one program called the fellowship
and the core of that is really the peer
exchange with a structured sort of
conversations over the course of ten
months and funding for the fellows to
create and and execute on collaborative
community product project whether that's
around music or something something in
their community related to the arts so
we're really excited to launch the
fellowship last year and that was
something we've been starting to plan
for and figure out as we were going into
the 15k last year and in addition to
those one-to-one programs we also have
two one-to-many programs so the
classroom connect is a collection of
curated virtual music and cultural
exchange modules that are offered in
high schools around the u.s. and global
music seminars are online courses taught
by musical faculty from different places
around the world to conservatory at
conservatories in different countries
around the world
so those are our four main programs I
just to give you a sense I mentioned a
few of these things of where we've come
from we launched a mentorship program
back in 2016 in 2018 we joined MIT
hanboks which was a great sort of
starting point for us in that journey
that I mentioned about rethinking some
of what teach learn would offer and what
we would be in the future we had our
first paid customer in January 2019
which was perfect timing to enter into
the sort of pre-competition mentorship
phase and we actually got a lot of value
out of speaking with our mentor during
the 15k competition thinking about how
do we really capitalize on that first
paid customer and think about doubling
down on that part of our programming in
April we did we were very
excited to win the creative arts
competition and it was also an exciting
month when we were officially received
our 501c3 registration and then in
October we launched two of the new
programs the fellowship and the global
music seminars and now in spring of 2020
we've expanded classroom connect program
to three high schools in the Boston area
and we are really excited for the
fellowship projects to they're just
starting to wrap up their ten months in
the in the coming months and the fellows
are starting to implement and work on
their community projects of actually
working right now to get funding to one
of our fellows who's ready to go in
Argentina he's working on a really
interesting sort of children's book
mapped to music it should be really cool
so that's just starting to happen and
within a couple months we'll be seeing
else 126 of those projects finished and
and all the awesome results from around
the world I want to just introduce you
to the team in addition to myself
Derrick and Bob and Chiaki it's all four
of us volunteering our time is a passion
project for us on the evening and
weekends all of you know what drew us to
teach to learn was all of our background
and in music education and musicians
ourselves of the countries we've worked
in around the world and all that
experience meeting and interacting with
people all around the world so it's very
international sort of team and with a
very international focus for the 15k
competition is just to give you a little
sense of how that funding helped us
advance the organisation a good chunk of
that funding went towards programming a
big part of that is was towards the
fellowship proof of concept so we had
this idea as a bit of an ambitious idea
to do the fellowship program when we
didn't really have the fund to make it
happen because we're funding each of
those fellows to do those community
projects but it was a bit of a chicken
and egg because we wanted to we wanted
to get universities and maybe
orchestras and other music programs
involved and sponsoring fellows but we
didn't really have any kind of proof to
show what that program could look like
what those results would actually look
like
so the 15k could not have come at a
better time
for us to really just kind of
short-circuit that that cycle and skip
ahead to actually having a proof of
concept now after ten months that we can
take to build partnerships with some of
the partners I mentioned and really have
tangible evidence of the impact so in
addition to a proof of concept for that
flagship program it also helps us expand
and test different models for classroom
connect so that additional funding has
gone a long way in growing that part of
the business and you really like I
mentioned earlier the men we kind of
double down in that area after some of
our conversations with our 15k mentor
thinking about okay if if people are
willing to pay for this service this is
an area we should really investigate and
try to and perfect so that we can kind
of support our hybrid business model of
both revenue and individual donations
and grant funding so that's that was
really good advice and we ran with it on
the other side we we also put money
towards editing and developing and
producing all of the really awesome
material that's been coming in Derek and
Bob over the last summer we're traveling
and I got to visit some of our fellows
in person and capture some of the work
that they're doing and as well as the
projects are starting to ramp up and
people are dr. fellows are documenting
their their activities we just have a
lot of really interesting stuff coming
in that we want to turn into compelling
materials and messaging that can help us
then bring this programs or any of these
programs to new partners and finally
we've been investing in building our own
platform online right now we're using
readily available free to use tools for
the most part to run these programs but
our vision is to have a place where
fellows and other participants can come
login and we can we can sort of have
more control over the user experience in
the future but we're not you know we're
not quite there yet we're hoping to get
there soon this is a little bit of a
visual on the fellowship program just to
give you a sense of you know eighty
eleven I think we can't can't see your
screen at the moment I'm so sorry
you can't fit it I think you've blown
off screen share okay let me exit this
have you not been able to see it for a
while okay okay let me in here Oh
sounded great okay so this is where I
was and that okay that was where the
funding went and now this is a visual on
the fellowship program so just saying
that it really gives you a sense of
scale in terms of the connections there
that are being made just within the
fellowship program
eighty eight thousand kilometers between
26 fellows and 16 countries it's pretty
phenomenal when you when you really put
it on a map and it's such an amazing
group of people we had the pleasure
recently of connecting with everyone in
three separate zoom calls just as sort
of a midpoint check-in and you know we
as as most organizations right now are
having to figure out how to adapt many
of these activities and our activities
due to covert 19 but you know we're in a
pretty good position of already being
online first and having the tool set up
to do that so you know on the one hand
yes we are connecting over zoom like
everybody else in these days but you
know even if things were different we
would still be have to connect over zoom
because we can never get everybody in
person together but the fellows are
really thinking creatively and working
hard right now at adapting their
projects to make them safe for
themselves in their communities and you
know we had some really awesome ideas
sort of a couple months
ago that needed to be changed and what
they're coming up with now are also
fantastic ideas so you know we're trying
to be iterative and flexible as well as
our as our fellows so I'll just leave
you with a video we're going to try
again and just Susan interrupts me if if
it's not working okay unless you guys
just want to uh do again this video is
just to give you a sense of one of our
fellows in Calcutta Amitabha let's see
if this works
[Music]
and you live in village is this how I
can express myself to God much can hear
the audio I can't see it you might need
to share this the actual screen as
opposed to just the PowerPoint great yep
maybe share your desktop that's it sure
that's probably what happened last time
all right I'm closing this I'm resuming
this share and let's try this can you
see that right now yes okay let's try
again I can express myself to God
[Music]
no bottle
consider that a do we apply a bisque
White House
versus Rizzi well you can just
concentrate on expressing yourself
[Music]
great I'm glad that that worked and now
that I figured that out I'm going to try
to show you the other video well I've
still got you so let me know if this
does not work
hi my name is sammy stephens I'm from
Eastman that name usually residing in
Brooklyn New York right now camping out
in Carrabassett Valley I sing and play a
bit of keys and when I teach I learned
hi my name is Alec Oh from Argentina my
name Sock'em and I'm from Iraq Mosul hi
my name is Tatiana burn Argentina hi I'm
Camille I live in Auckland New Zealand i
play the oboe and when I teach I learned
[Music]
my name is Percy my name is Roberto
Blanco and I am from Mexico my name is
Kevin and I'm from Kampala Uganda hi my
name is Julia I'm from California and I
play the viola and when I teach Tyler
[Music]
great we did it I feel very accomplished
I just want to say a really big thank
you from myself dared shocky and
everyone who participates in teach to
learn and all the new participants we've
been able to bring in thanks to the
funding and the support it's a really
big thank you to the 15k we've had a
fantastic experience with you and really
it helped us advance the organization
drastically so thanks and I happy to
take any questions and please feel free
if you're interested in the arts if
you're interested in connecting cultural
music exchange or just want to support
what we're doing that's our info email
there on the screen and as well our
website thank you so much mark what a
fantastic presentation it's so wonderful
to hear about all the great things that
have happened for teach to learn in the
last year if there are any questions
from the audience feel free to put them
into the Q&A box right now we can answer
those quickly and if there aren't any we
will transition into some videos about
caste and some of the other projects
that our office does while the judges
continue to deliberate we're hoping that
we'll be able to announce their decision
around 6:15 or so um but again you know
deliberations always flex a little bit
so hopefully hopefully we'll able to
announce things as soon as we can um I
don't see any questions yet um mark
thank you so much for joining us was
really a pleasure to hear from you oh
yeah great to be back great to hear some
of the other pitches and good luck to
all the finalists oh I think I see one
oh yeah oh okay
struggles and how you overcame them over
the past year um yes great that's a
great question we've we've had a lot of
bumps in the road I you know I think
Cova 19 is probably the biggest that we
face because so so much is riding on so
much time and honestly funding has been
invested into the fellowship program in
the projects we really want to see the
results and we
on track to see some really exciting
results and now with the pivot away from
in-person projects you know we really
had to get creative and support our
fellows a lot more than we you know we
expected to or anticipated doing having
to do in the first place a way that we I
think we've done a pretty good job
addressing that by by like making sure
that we reinforce the community of
fellows and for the teach to learn
community so having those that midpoint
check-in was actually the first time
that we'd all had them in one place and
after we did it we thought to ourselves
like why haven't we been doing this the
whole time because the energy was
fantastic people were talking to each
other and you know wasn't just the
one-to-one it was the group and people
would say you know I had this idea and
now I don't know what to do with it and
then other people say well I you know I
had an idea like that but now I'm going
to do this and I like that so you know
having those we're actually having
another one in a week just to keep the
conversation going and basically it's
less about us figuring everything out
and more about letting our community
connect with each other to help each
other so you know there have been other
examples but that one is has really been
one that I think that we're going to get
over pretty well and we're excited to
see what the what the projects are great
well thanks again for for having us
appreciate being invited back and
sharing some of the updates and please
feel free to reach out you know we're
always happy to talk to people we
actually collaborated with a few of the
other finalists from the 15k last year
where they're just keeping in touch
personally or working on some side
projects together 15k is a great way to
meet other people working in arts and
technology I think you're mu
but I will mute my day yeah thank you
thank you again so much for for coming
and talking and it's a it's great to
hear that you're still in touch with
other people in the 15k that's awesome
thanks again thank you I'm so we will
play a couple of videos about on some
other programs that the Center for
attentive technology and other things of
the Arts at MIT are working on and
please watch the space will let you know
as soon as we have a result from the
judges all right welcome back everybody
the judges have completed their
deliberation after some very lively
discussions about all of your fantastic
projects I am thrilled to announce our
winners of the 20 2015 Kay creative arts
competition beginning with our audience
choice award in the amount of $500 it is
congratulations to team on make moving
on to our third prize award in the
amount of $1,000 that will be going to
material future lab congratulations and
now for our second prize in the amount
of $2,500 that goes to verified and
finally the first prize winners of the
2020 MIT creative arts competition
taking home an incredible $15,000 is
congratulations thank you to all of the
teams for your incredible effort for all
of your hard work throughout this entire
process it's been an absolute joy to
work with all of you thank you again to
all of the attendees to our judges to
the Office of the Arts to all of the
mentors to mentally to everybody for
helping this to happen couldn't have
done it without you all and with that I
believe that we have now concluded the
20 2015 Kay creative arts competition
thank you all for being here for all of
your support this has been a joy and I
look forward to seeing you all in 2021
thank you so so much
thank you guys great work everyone
congratulation